Das ist wirklich sensationell einem hobby astronomen aus argentinien ist jetzt das gelungen was sich
suchroboter und forschungsteams weltweit schon lange erträumen das leitbild einer supernova was einer lücke seines
dachfensters hat erstmalig eine supernova live auf fotos festhalten können die ganze
unglaubliche geschichte jetzt ein klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Erst vor kurzem haben wir von einem funkamateur hier berichtet der tatsächlich den totgeglaubten
nasa-satelliten image aufgespürt hat und auch diese geschichte hier beweist mal wieder dass
amateure eine wichtige rolle bei neuen wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnissen spielen können jedenfalls konkret geht es um viktor bout so aus argentinien
im september
2016 hatte sich der hobby astronom eine neue kamera für sein 40 zentimeter teleskop geleistet in der nacht des 26
Septembers dann passierte es er hatte teile des daches nicht einmal richtig aufgeschoben um seinen nachbarn nachts nicht
zu stören
Doch auch wenn die bedingungen alles andere als ideal waren er wollte auf alle fälle
Seine neue kamera testen wo so richtete sein teleskop auf die galaxie ngc
610 sie ist seit dem 19 jahrhundert, im sogenannten new channel katalog aufnehmen oder ein cluster auf stars eben ngc
verzeichnet in dem alle galaktischen sternhaufen galaxien usw
Aufgelistet sind diese galaxie war für buße zu diesem zeitpunkt wohl das einfach sinn testobjekt denn sie befand sich direkt
Senkrecht über ihn somit hatte die lichtverschmutzung nur wenig einfluss
Buß stellte die belichtungszeit auf 20 sekunden ein die erste bild reiterei die nach 20 minuten 40 bilder zum ergebnis
hatte ja die waren nicht sagen doch die ergebnisse buß zweiter bildreihe sind dagegen umso spektakulärer
Denn plötzlich entwickelte sich eine supernova in der frühen phase die zu diesem zeitpunkt nur im
computermodellen existiert hat ihr name sn
Gg obwohl die lichtbedingungen alles andere als optimal waren lieferte buß neue kamera
brauchbare bilder denn die supernova war sehr hell und dem hobby astronom gelang es tatsächlich die steigende helligkeit zu
dokumentieren und verwertbare daten zu liefern und das obwohl supernovae eher selten sind studien zufolge
passieren sie in einer durchschnittlichen galaxie mit etwa
100 milliarden sternen nur etwa alle 100 jahre bus beobachtung waren also ein absoluter volltreffer
vergleichbar mit dem hauptgewinn beim lotto spielen die wahrscheinlichkeit in einer einstündigen beobachtung aller galaxien sie die erste stunde des
aufleuchten einer supernova zu zu bekommen liegt bei eins zu einer million das ist also wirklich einmalig denn bei früheren
Supernova entstehung waren die forschungsteams immer ein bisschen zu spät dran ist ja logisch
Weil erst muss sie ja anfangen so explodieren und dann kam er erst die teleskope ausrichten zum beispiel auf die supernova sn
2011 diese wurde zwar durch kammern und röntgenblitze beobachtet aber erst später band eben
im sichtbaren licht bei der supernova case and 2011
War man früher dran doch auch hier verpasste man die ankunft der schockwelle an der sternoberfläche
Wenn erst einmal die supernova
Bekannt wird geht die suche erst richtig los wanted der stern der explodiert war nicht wirklich einfach beim millionen lichtjahren entfernung
Denn die ist so hell die supernova dass man gar nicht exakt wissen kann
Wo ist jetzt der stern sowie verschiedene daten der supernova wie beispielsweise der helligkeit und der aufgezeichneten
lichtspektrum kann dann analysiert werden welche sterne in frage kommen viktor bout so ist jetzt jedenfalls achtung co autor in einer der
Renommiertesten wissenschaftlichen fachzeitschriften der welt nature tempo so meldete seine entdeckung ganz schnell an die international astronomical
junien und an weitere wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler nach vielen untersuchungen gehen die beteiligten
Forschungsteams davon aus dass es sich
Um einen doppelstern handeln muss 19,5 sonnenmassen hatte wohl der explodierte stern sein begleiter
13,5 sonnenmassen ein anderes modell kommt zu dem ergebnis dass der stern a15 und dass der stern b
Als 25 sonnenmassen gehabt haben muss welches modell der wahrheit
Am nächsten kommt das wird man spätestens dann sehen wenn der zweite stern die
verblassende supernova dann später überstrahlt davon sind dann die forschungsteams
Überzeugt der zweite stern sollte weit genug entfernt gewesen sein um die supernova zu überstehen fest steht auch dass
basars bilder und datensätze die theoretischen prognosen weitestgehend
bestätigen bei der ankunft der schockwelle an der sternoberfläche stieg die helligkeit zwar etwas langsamer
als vorausgesagt an doch der grund dafür liegt wahrscheinlich darin dass der stern
Im vorfeld schon große massen abgestoßen hatte so wurde ein teil des lichts blockiert oder
und da darf man auch dass davon auch nicht ausschließen dass diese erstmalige live beobachtung einer supernova wieder zu neuen ärger
wissen über
Supernovae führt wir dürfen auf jeden fall gespannt sein und zwar sehr gespannt wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema
supernovae und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video das melde ich euch dort
Eben vorab und das garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von krieg zum mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
Mit abstimmung mitbestimmen was sie auf dem kanal passiert einfach hier draufklicken
Und natürlich nicht das aber mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter. Also hier dafür drauf klicken da geht es um eine zombie
Supernova auch sehr spannend denn sonst würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran